there you go
we're live all right hello welcome to
game sports coverage of e3 2014 Desir is
over the conference's are done and we
are here live on GameSpot Samsung stage
for day one of three days of coverage
with all the best games here in Los
Angeles I am delighted to be joined by
mr. Sean Murray of hello games a man old
friend good to see you again yeah yeah
you pop up on GameSpot stuff every we
get you on we had you in the UK we've
had you in it in the LA out in the San
Francisco office as well every time I
see you some new crazy thing has
happened and I'm watching the the Sony
conference yesterday and it's like oh
look Sean's up on the stage showing off
no man sky I came that made a massive
splash back here earlier this year first
of all what was it like for you actually
stepping out on that stage with all
those people there it was it Sade it was
just it's a Davi you do this kind of
thing yeah you get out camera and so for
that this is not what I do most of what
I wanted to do not in front of that many
people it's like yeah it's insane you
know like that someone was telling me
kind of basically billions of people are
watching like bore boarded the
population of Ireland yeah which were
probably you just start thinking that
before you go out yeah I did a great job
though did you go off a teleprompter at
any stage did you kind of yeah yeah like
they had a teleprompter and and I'd
written a script but then it just kind
of I don't know abortions yes are
talking it seems really genuine it
seemed like you were you're kind you're
kind of yeoman was was I was like
driving them crazy with the teleprompter
they're trying to follow what I was
saying like which bit is he on now just
see all these screens go up and down
excellent okay let's talk about no man's
sky you guys showed this off earlier
this year made a big splash with that
trailer and the gameplay trailer you
show it again this time have used up
awesome track again use very similar
kind of feel the taking off but this
time you both showed all this new sort
of the animal the creatures that we
created the the
phears and also descending into the
planet what what are you trying to tell
people about what no man sky is in that
trailer I think one thing that's a good
question one thing that I really wanted
to show was that this isn't just like an
ambient experience right there's like
this is a universe but it's one that has
a lot of danger and things in it so like
and you know on the ground there are
other creatures there's an ecology and
there's like you're not necessarily the
top of the food chain yeah another thing
so there's danger from that point of
view but then when you go into space
space isn't just empty you know it's
really full there are freighters there's
fleet there's you know kind of pirates
space stations military you know there's
a real ecosystem within space as well
and I guess the other thing was just
showing that it's other seamless is a
weird word but like it's all there it's
all real you know when you when you
actually look up at that dinosaur yeah
there's a planet behind it that's the
planet the you end up flying down notice
that you can see like some of those
floating islands that you fly past you
could see those kind of on that planet
and it's all it's there it's real it's
not some skybox or whatever and that's
kind of what we wanted to get across
excellent I've got a bunch of questions
for you but I want to let the folks at
home know that if you have any questions
at all for Sean and use at Daniel Dwyer
on Twitter and I'll pop them up and here
on my Twitter and ask them but I've got
loads of questions for myself
it seems to be the type of game that
invites questions that like this this
seems like there's almost too much
possibility and I want to talk about the
stuff that's happening on the planet
first of all okay when you are like
walking around exploring this this
planet what what are you what are your
quests be them like self fulfilling
quests or ones that the game is giving
you yeah I guess like quests is that
terrible words it's that thing that I
don't in my mind as soon as somebody
says it I picture like flying down to a
planet and somebody just coming up to
you and saying I've lost my three
chickens my space chicken you know there
are three different planets can you find
them that kind of thing and we you know
lots of games have that
it's great and all that but we just want
to stay so far away from that one yeah
right this is like it's not a sandbox
it's just a living breathing universe
and there's a lot that you can get up to
it in it but we're not saying find the
three space chickens right so things
that you can do like you actually see
resources and think said that yeah you
know and you're scanning for those those
are really valuable and you could be
scary for creatures or whatever you
could also be fighting those creatures
that could be something that you decide
to do right and wipe out a species or
whatever you don't and but then in space
as well there is so much to do but you
know between like trading fighting you
know formulators is whatever you want to
do within that and we just want to
create a universe that has emergent
gameplay I guess and that the players
will find that themselves the kind of
key driving force though is this I was
saying last night that every everyone
starts on a different planet and
actually the way we do that is I love it
it's like Scientology everyone gets
their own planet except for the stars
yeah we haven't been compared to sighs I
don't know if it's what that we welcome
but careful you're in Los Angeles buddy
okay then we we start everyone at the
outside getting of a galaxy basically of
one galaxy and then you know that a core
quest I guess you want to put it that
way core thing that I think we've all
undertake is to make the journey to the
center okay that garlic is that
something you can do on your own or is
playing with others and like trying to
help each other like part of a sh I
think it's it's kind of naturally part
of us if you got one thing that's like
really key to it right is if you play
and you're the very first player and you
bring up your galactic map when you're
in that galaxy like everything will be
there yeah and you will see like
everything
on the map you will be able to go to all
the planets and all the suns and moons
and everything like that but they all
just say unknown and because nothing's
been discovered yet right so the planets
themselves are a known quantity but it's
like finding what's near that they're
there but you don't know whether they're
hospitable you don't know where those
resources they're you don't know whether
there are Space Station's you don't know
whether traded posts you know anything
like that and then as you explore more
you will find those things and you can
upload that information and that map is
being filled out but not just by you by
everybody yeah so even if you don't want
to cooperate with people they are
helping you you know together you know
what we find this that people are
naturally building almost like roots
right you say where I am there's nothing
known around me yeah but I can see over
there if I make a journey over there
there's kind of this nice plotted out
Ruka where I can see some so you guys
seem to be very much like focusing on
discovery rather than say economics like
if you look at something like Eve or
right exactly you know but the game is
about exploration but and it's about
discovery but that's what science
fiction's about yeah you know and
science fiction if you take Star Trek
right you know it is about exploration
discovery but they still always end up
in you know combat situations yes or you
know a dangerous situation so it's not
an ambient experience it's not just
exploring looking at trees yeah you can
do that if you want you know but that's
kind of a style I play so let's talk
about the combat then we saw it's it's
kind of this thing where it looks like
this wonderful world to explore and then
some people my friend another bit
jarring that's Allegiant you just
smoking fools like is the comment the
game is it mostly is it you against AI
fleets is it you partnering up with
other people to take to co-op ai or are
you fighting other players a lot
something that's hard to get across is
that this universe is so vast yeah that
the likelihood is you're you're going to
come across AI we need AI to populate it
yeah because you and I if we're playing
you know we we won't
say let's meet up you know it doesn't
make sense
we're light-years apart like literally
you know could it take could it take a
very long time to get to the other side
of the lair
yeah like ridiculously long tava that's
one of the reasons he would say upgrade
your ship yeah right and because you
want a hyperdrive you want to be able to
jump between solar systems but yeah you
could fly endlessly right you know and
that's what I want this there's that
story recently of that guy who like
warps you know forever in Minecraft
yeah yeah right and yeah you could you
could totally do that and hopefully
someone will it probably failed
otherwise right if somebody does just
fly for like five years straight your
invisible wall at the end and I've got
so many questions coming in I want to
come to this one from Black Mesa on
Twitter
and what can you tell us about the
combat or dangerous situations in terms
of like ground ground combat do you
would you be protecting a planet or any
stage so you're not there is the ecology
right and that's just kind of naturally
there and there is a like I'm terrible
for this kind of stuff
there should be like a press planting
like that right there is something give
us a little something you know there is
like I guess a malevolent force within
the UK right so there is something that
drives that emergent situation right
that we we haven't shown and when we
show it we'll talk about it okay fair
enough right blue don't want it to be
like I said just fodder yeah or
something yeah another question may be
similar to that Patrick Jacobs on
Twitter asking is there a story within
no man's sky or are you trying allowing
players to create their own story what's
absolutely that and that's what I was
saying about start to give you on a
different planet
you know like everyone's story will be
unique I mean if you you and I even if
we want to we can't have the same story
yeah you know our experience and and
what you'll have seen when you're
playing it will just I will want to know
about it you know because I will
probably never get to experience
you know I found this or I saw that or
whatever you know I'm this type of
planet this type of creature and I'll
play the you know I can play for a
hundreds of hours and I will never see
that yeah
I will never visit the planet so you've
been to don't you to come visit my
favorite a little more questions about
the soundtrack obviously you're using
that am that song from sixty days of
starting and I what are you going to do
in terms of the soundtrack for the final
game you're going to work with other
bands to actually the the kind of
montage thing that we did at the end
that's 65 days as well okay we've kind
of become friends with the guys yeah
we're mailing me last night and
congratulating me and stuff we actually
wanted them to play like last night and
we like cancelled it like two days out
okay because it was nobody was prepared
for it and there was no time for
rehearsal at bigs like that and at what
I came into the Saudi conference yeah
when I met the team for the first time
because we've been in the UK and just
talking to them on the phone I came into
the stadium and they were like hey guys
guys these are the guys who wanted a
live band really brilliant he became
infamous yeah these idiots but yeah we
really wanted that it they're they're
gonna be I hope really closely linked
with automatically admit did seem to be
a real good hook or what you guys are
showing visually as well and another
question Stephanie L will do is having a
bass customizing it in such possible no
man sky so you'll obviously be
customizing you ship will it be other
things you'll be customizing what we
want people and to encourage people to
do is to go on a journey this is not
about just staying on one planet okay
you know setting up a shop or whatever I
think people will
some people will but that's not core to
the game right what I would I'd be
slightly disappointed if everyone just
started up on their planet and they
didn't see them like I don't want to be
on them I don't want to be involved this
space war here I like this planet in
it's nice to chill that am yeah it's
it's another question that's kind of
coming to my mind is it like it looks a
bit like I don't to make too too many
comparisons but like FTL for instance
again where you were compelled for some
reason to continue to get your endpoint
and
hypothetically how long could that
endpoint be and would you if you got
there would you be encouraged to stay or
would you want to go back from the start
and try again
so it's you know go back to the start
try get it's not that type of game okay
it's not you know the idea of levels
quests all that like throw that house
right and you can play forever like
obviously you know it's it's I know
that's a little bit mind-blowing because
it's it's infinite you know this is the
this the really weird thing right you
can play for a million hours right and
the amount that you will have seen in
that time is still infinitesimally small
I know any number you divided by
infinity it's a it approaches zero right
so yeah what you seem to be doing is
just diving into science fiction
literature and like 3:00 a.m. I'm drunk
and I'm reading about astrophysics on
Wikipedia and it's melting my brain and
trying to turn that into a game yeah
something like that
a little touch so homework so the
multiplayer then in that respect it
almost seems like we're coming across
somebody else be like a moment will it
be will it will it be something that
happens all the time in day to day
gameplay or will it be like something
you'll actually have to like put time in
to try to do in terms of multiplayer you
know like we're not building an MMO that
isn't that isn't the type of game that
we're making right and like it's almost
an anti-social game because MMO is
trying to like put you into lobbies and
push you together we're fair we're
firing everyone across the universe
they'll probably never see each other
but there is the ability to communicate
and work with other people but if you
want to I won't go into loads of the
details but if you want to think about
games I really admire would be like
journey and how it does it Dark Souls
and how it does multiplayer you know
those are games that that experience for
me is really fitting right yeah and so
many questions in here and how many oh
yeah let's talk about the creatures for
a second okay I know the answer to this
but a lot of people been asking about it
so in terms of the creatures some folks
are asking how many creatures are there
obviously have this procedurally
generated world's the animals in the
ecology is up the same situation will
they be flying massive flying beasts
massive beasts what we do is we create
like a a Genesis of a creature right so
we you know it is built it's not it's
built out of a kind of it's almost like
building something out of play
yeah right and so we we build a creature
and we will build so you build a cat
okay when you build a cat it's almost
like the game the tech that we've built
and I describe it this way
you know Tony Hawk's yes right what you
would create a skater can't wait to see
where this one goes
you don't you create a skater or or like
a Tiger Woods or whatever like and you
could move all the sliders yeah and you
would create any variation thereof so
imagine that we're doing that for
everything yeah for every tree for
rebuilding ship and mounting right so
all those players we're not creating any
ecology in this game now no but what
what's happening is that one of our
artists will create a cat but by doing
that they'll also create a lion and a
tiger and a panther and every variant of
that of that four-legged creature that
you know has the walks in that way and
but like continuing on that to be as
mutated as you can possibly imagine it
so it sounds a bit like Spore in the
terms of sliders will there be any sort
of massive penis monster like inevitably
if you've got more sliders to discuss
somewhere out there is a massive penis
monster all right this is always where
your mind goes you know me Sean and
house-arrest relooking what are you
gonna be guys you know you've got to be
doing showing off any more gameplay
anytime soon yeah we're kind of like
we're not on the show floor just because
it's a it's a weird cave for people to
just yeah but like just play that for a
million hours and see nothing
all right well Sean Murray it's always a
pleasure to have you on friends that
great to see something from back home as
well as every and we're gonna do an
interview later on today for a next big
game on GameSpot calm ask you guys a
bunch more questions about no one's guy
have a great III buddy thanks very much
for coming on again love
III staged samsung stage here continues
we've got CounterSpy LittleBigPlanet 3
I'm battlefield hardline coming up ever
right now here's a mashup of what
happened at Microsoft's press conference
yesterday